what's going on gq i'm maddie conrad and
today
we're gonna do something a little crazy
[Music]
that's right today i'm shaving off my
beard
i've had a beard for over 10 years i
don't remember what my face looks like
and uh yeah it's a little unnerving
it's a little it's a little scary i'm
going to walk you through the steps to
both physically and emotionally
by old friend goodbye handle removing
your beard from your face
i'm also gonna highlight a few other
beard styles that you can try
on the way down i figure if i'm gonna
take this off
why don't we have a little bit of fun
with it along the way so here's what
you're gonna need to get this done
you're going to need a clipper and
you're probably going to want a trimmer
the difference is the clipper will take
off most of the hair
but the trimmer will create nice looking
outlines or it'll shave it down really
close to the skin
i think we're going to start with
something that suits a narrow face shape
i've always liked to wear my beard kind
of square like a lumberjack
but let's see what happens when we slim
it down a little bit and give it
something a little pointier
the duck's tail so first thing i'm going
to do is i'm going to set my clipper all
the way forward to zero
so i want to be the shortest possible
length that i can make it
then i'm basically going to treat my
beard kind of like a hedge
i'm just going to take a pick i'm going
to pull it all out
make sure it's nice and fluffy
all right let's get into this i'm gonna
take my clipper upside down and i'm just
gonna draw a straight line
down into the corner
all right so you can see the bulk of the
hair is coming out of that corner
pretty good you want to take your
clipper
and you want to set it to make it kind
of a straight line
right down nice and angled right into
your adam's apple
[Music]
every time i do this i'm going to take a
little bit of a pass
i'm going to pull out all the tangly
hairs that are underneath
and make sure get it nice and clean and
linear all right now we're going to take
this cheek and we're just going to
narrow it down a little bit
so the way i do that is i think again
kind of like a flat panel like i'm
making a wall something looks like this
so i'm going to puff the hair out just a
little bit making sure that there's no
tangles in the sides then i'm going to
take my clipper invert it and make a
wall straight down
i don't know if you can see this but i'm
freaking out already when it comes to
the other side we're going to switch
hands
and we're going to do the same thing
we're going to start from the outside
and work our way in
to the center of the beard once you've
got the inside of the beard
which is this kind of bulky area once
you have that sorted out
i'm then going to take my clipper same
idea and i'm just going to punch a line
at the bottom and i'm going to go
straight down
just like that make a nice clean wall
all right once we've got the interior of
the shape done you're going to take your
trimmer
and you're going to outline the beard
outlining the beard always kind of
brings the shape together it always
makes it pop a little bit so i'm going
to start at the baseline
and the baseline is this v shape that
goes from the corner of my jaw
down towards the adam's apple
i always turn the trimmer over when i
want to go and remove hair
raking with this kind of emotion kind of
irritates my skin
makes it really itchy makes it red so
i'll make sure i don't do that i like to
use a flat
smooth side and i clean up to the line
that i've created
[Music]
now we're going to tackle the top line
the top line is this little edge up here
where the beard intersects the face you
usually want that to be either really
straight and square
or you want something slightly rounded
depending on your face shape
if you have a fuller face shape you want
to do something that is really lean and
angular
but if you have something that is a
little bit more on the narrow side you
want to try and give it a soft rounded
look
[Music]
the trick is getting them even not quite
yet
the last part that we want to tackle is
right back here this is the area that
grows below the ear to the corner of the
jaw
i find the best thing to do here is
brush the hair back very very slightly
turn your trimmer on its side and you
want to punch a line in
starting from in front of your ear all
the way down to the corner
and brush the hairs back just a little
bit more make sure i got them all
much better this is the duck's tail
because it looks like a duck's tail
leonardo dicaprio in django unchained
had a ducktale
keanu reeves ducktale and a ducktales
style definitely suits somebody with
more narrow face shape
so far not too different but i have a
feeling as we get shorter and shorter
i'm gonna start to look a bit weird so
as we get a little bit tighter on the
sides we're gonna need to use something
to
control the length so i'm gonna put a
guard on my clipper
this is a number two guard i'm gonna fit
it on the clipper like that
with my clippers still all the way
closed and what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna use it right against my face
and i'm gonna go downwards as you work
downwards it gets a smoother finish on
it
so if you go up it's gonna get really
short really quick
and even though we're taking it all off
i still want to have a little bit of fun
so i'm going to take this clipper with
my guard and work straight down
just brush the hairs out a little bit so
make sure i get them all
[Music]
all right now the sides are nice and
lean we're going to take the bottom nice
and short
so what i'm doing is taking my clipper
and punching a straight line
right across the bottom
that's going to give me a nice square
chin shape then what i'm going to do
is i'm going to create a nice little
line from the corner of my jaw right
down to that front part
now to make this a real low rider beard
we have to take that top line
and we have to drop it down a little bit
towards the jaw
so i'm going to first carve a little
line down where my sideburn is
then i'm going to create a nice little
line towards the corner of my mouth
[Music]
this is already more of my face than
i've seen in the last decade and a lot
more neck than i remember
so here we have more of a low rider
style beard it's a little bit more
square
the cheek lines drop down a little bit
lower which is actually really good for
guys that have
a little bit of a strong jaw or a fuller
face shape kind of look like
alan from the hangover one of the most
important parts about this town of a
beard is that it actually connects all
the way up through the sideburns so it's
not faded out it's still very strong
linear so when you make these nice
strong lines it changes the shape of
your face just slightly
so you can see it looks a little bit
leaner and a little bit longer
honestly i feel really uncomfortable
right now all right next up i'm going to
try something that i'm pretty sure has
never been done before
but hear me out
[Music]
now to the outside observer you know
they just see a goatee
you know looks like an old cowboy kind
of thing
but it really is
there's a very convincing face mask
but in all seriousness guys that's just
a joke mask up it's important
so at this point i got some options i
guess i mean i could go for like a
handlebar mustache
i don't know there's something i've been
seeing a little bit in hollywood lately
and i kind of wanted to try it out
let's go that route i'm going to make a
van dyke out of this and
it's a really subtle change but the
first thing you want to do is protect
your mustache so make sure you don't get
the mustache in with the rest
so i'm just going to take a blow dryer
and i'm going to blow it out of the way
well that looks good and there we go
that's a little better now the thing
that makes it a van dyke is we got a
little bit of a diamond-shaped goatee
with a long twisty mustache so all i
really need to do is just disconnect
this part and give it a little bit more
of a diamond shape and i can do that
with my trimmer
[Music]
all right i just need to try and make it
look even on the other side
all right when you want to get some
shape in your mustache use a little bit
of product
i'm going to use a custom made mustache
wax
this stuff is usually really really
sticky so you want to put in your
fingers
and you want to rub it together just to
melt the wax
i'm going to work it through everything
and just
sculpt it slightly so what i'm doing is
i'm going to work through here
and i'm going to give the ends just a
bit of a twist i don't want to turn them
forward
i just want to pinch them so i turn them
upwards
this is essentially a van dyke it is a
disconnected goatee
with a longer mustache the van dyke is
named after
anthony van dyke who was a flemish
painter
everybody knows that i had a mustache
just before i had a beers
you grow a mustache and then you realize
that facial hair kind of works on you
and then you're like oh i'm just gonna
go all the way and grow a beard
oh i'm gonna miss this mustache i'm like
i've only had it for a few minutes and
i'm i'm already getting so attached
okay so of all of the styles so far i
think i can maybe pull this one off
let's get on with it you know what um
i'm kind of digging a mustache so
i think i'm gonna see what my face looks
like without the goatee
[Music]
oh my god well
hello chin i haven't seen you in a while
i'm just happy there's still only one
that's a relief i'm not go ladies that's
actually kind of a relief well i'll be
honest with you
it looks a lot cooler with the goatee
there's something fun about just
wiggling your mustache though isn't
there
let's see what other mustache styles we
can do
all right you undoubtedly recognize this
little number from
shows like magnum pi or pretty much
every cop show you've ever seen in your
life
to get a mustache like this really what
it takes is just combing everything
straight down and using the shape of
your lip line to create more of a
straight across feel on the mustache
[Music]
it's nice i feel like maybe what's
giving it that like 70s
porn star stash vibe is the sideburns
those gotta go
yeah yeah that's better
this mustache makes me look like a guy
named ron
well i mean there's ron swanson maybe a
little bit of ron burgundy in there
you stay classy gq
my face is already cold so last stop on
the mustache express
this is the weirdest thing i have ever
done you need just a little bit of
pomade
so this is that really pretentious tiny
little french mustache
and we we
are going to apply the pomade
[Music]
hello so think like john waters or
french waiter or
antonio banderas in zorro although i'm
pretty sure they just drew that on with
a pencil crayon
basically i think this is a really good
one for guys that don't have very
pronounced upper lips and want to leave
something up there that makes it look
like they have a top lip
this is the most awkward i've felt in
years you would think
that at this point i would want to hang
on to just that last little bit of hair
on my face
but um my body is physically rejecting
this right now and it just it just wants
to get it off
[Music]
so here we go
in a weird way i feel a bit like a
turtle right now so
it's uh i mean i i think there's a shock
that comes with it
ice cream cones is a thing again soup
that's usually not for bearded folks i
look younger though don't i like
[Music]
here it is
for the next four weeks i'm going to be
growing my beard out which means i have
to go through that itchy and annoying
phase that gets most of us to just
shave so i think a really good thing for
you guys to do in the next four weeks if
you want to grow a beard with me
is make sure you have yourself a good
face wash and a good moisturizer it's
really going to help with the itch and
it's going to keep things soft and
supple
do not shave anything just let it grow
for four weeks
and at the end of that i'm going to show
you how to carve it into a strong beard
shape that's going to give you all the
things that you need to get through
the rough spots if you guys have any
questions about growing a beard any
challenges that you're facing throw them
at me
we're going to do this together all
right so make sure you reach out
and check out the next video until then
good luck
and good grooming
you